willkommen zur
heutigen sitzung ähm das thema
ist
robotik und autonome systeme
ein eher angewandtes
thema im vergleich zu den letzten
sitzungen zunächst möchte ich
ganz kurz aktuelle bücher zu diesem
thema von catherine miselhon, professorin
für
philosophie an der universität
göttingen
und vorstellen  Das erste Buch ist eine Einführung in die
Maschinenethik,
es legt sozusagen
die Grundlage für weitere Diskussionen und ihr
neueres Buch
handelt von künstlicher Intelligenz und
Empathie. Es ist ein eher angewandtes Buch
, das sich mit
dem Leben mit
Robotern, sogar mit Sexrobotern, beschäftigt  wirklich
interessantes thema ich kann die
lektüre empfehlen
wir werden diese bücher auch in der
nächsten der nächsten sitzungen im nächsten
januar besprechen
wenn es um eher angewandte fragen geht
aber nur als hintergrund sind diese bücher
wirklich interessant
aber heute in unserer sitzung wir  Ich möchte
einen aktuellen Artikel aus dem Jahr 2018 diskutieren
und ich denke, dass Arno
uns etwas über den Inhalt erzählen wird, den
ich auch geben werde  eine übersicht der
stichworte dieses artikels, die
für sie interessant sein könnten
ja ich
möchte nur ein paar sätze
zu diesem text sagen, der
kein sehr bekannter text ist, kein klassischer
text oder ähnliches, sondern ein
beitrag
zu einer aktuellen Debatte zu einer aktuellen
Diskussion
um die halbautomatischen autonomen Systeme
und insbesondere um autonome Waffen,
und ich denke,
obwohl dieser
Kontext dieser Debatte dieser ethische
Kontext der
Debatte ein völlig anderer ist als der
Kontext des Textes, den wir
letzte Woche
dort diskutiert haben  eine art
sagen wir mal eine art link
beide texte haben
aufgrund von referenzen
aufgrund von kontexten nicht sehr viel
miteinander zu tun, aber systematisch
würde ich sagen
sie haben eine gemeinsame art von
grundidee,
nämlich
zu
denken  Maschinen und spezifische Maschinen
halbautonome Maschinen und Maschinen
, die mit spezifischen Technologien
wie maschinellem Lernen verbunden sind, um sie
als Teil der
Gesellschaft zu betrachten  Ich praktiziere, sagen wir, als Teil
sozialer Umgebungen, sagen wir, ich habe
in Bezug auf den
Harry-Collins-Text von letzter Woche sehr hervorgehoben,
dass
dieser Text besonders interessant ist,
weil er
nicht den Menschen und seine
Intelligenz
und die Maschine und ihre Intelligenz und
sie vergleicht
vergleicht weder das menschliche Gehirn mit der
Modellierung des menschlichen Gehirns durch eine künstliche
Maschine, noch stellt es die Frage, auf welche
Weise Maschinen in soziale Praktiken eingebettet werden können
und durch deren Einbettung
sie möglicherweise in einem
bestimmten
begrenzten Umfang partizipieren könnten  in sozialen praktiken
und in sozialen umgebungen war das die
grundfrage von harry collins
und sicher erlaubt diese art des
denkens auch das ethische in gewisser weise zu fragen
oder in frage zu
stellen oder in gewisser weise zu
diskutieren  ethische Rolle
von Maschinen in einem bestimmten Kontext
und
die Art und Weise, wie wir Maschinen verwenden, die Art und Weise, wie
wir Maschinen entwerfen und die Art und Weise, wie wir
Praktiken entwerfen, in denen Maschinen eingesetzt werden  e
beteiligt,
und
das ist genau das, was ich denke,
der allgemeine Ansatz
dieses Textes von Filippo Santoni de Sioux
und Jeroen van der Hoefen. Ich bin mir
ziemlich unsicher, ob ich diese Namen
mehr oder weniger richtig ausgesprochen habe,
aber ich meine die Autoren von  diesen Text,
weil sie fragen,
auf welche Weise
autonome autonome Systeme, die
nicht völlig autonom sind, weil wir nicht
wollen, dass sie autonom sind,
wir in diesen Debatten nicht wollen,
dass autonome Waffensysteme selbst entscheiden,
ob sie sollen oder nicht
töten oder nicht,
sie fragen, auf welche Weise wir sie
kontrollieren könnten,
und diese Frage der Kontrolle
ist wichtig,
weil es eine Frage der
Verantwortung ist,
ja, in dieser Debatte ist klar, dass wir
vermeiden wollen, dass jemand sagen könnte, es
sei die Maschine und  Es war kein
Mensch, also gibt es keine Verantwortung dafür,
dass auf einmal 10 Menschen gestorben sind oder so
etwas, also geht es darum,
die Kontrolle zu erlangen oder die Kontrolle zu haben,
es geht darum
, eine Brandlücke zu vermeiden  Verantwortung,
und was ich an diesem Text besonders faszinierend finde
und möglicherweise müssen wir
das heute diskutieren,
ist,
dass sie
nicht nur danach fragen,
was passiert, wenn bestimmte Maschinen verwendet
werden, sondern auch darüber
diskutieren, wie wir
Maschinen
entwerfen sollten, die
es uns ermöglichen,
die Kontrolle darüber zu behalten  diese maschinen, also
fragen sie wirklich nach einem wertebasierten
design, sie fragten, wie wir
die soziale praxis gestalten sollten, in der
diese maschinen eingesetzt werden, auf
welche weise wir die szenarien
der nutzung und anwendung dieser maschinen gestalten sollten,
und ich denke das  ist mehr oder weniger auch eine
frage nach der sozialität der sozialen
rolle dieser maschinen in bezug auf
die frage, wie wir die kontrolle gewinnen oder
behalten können und
verantwortungslücken vermeiden
und ich habe den eindruck, ich bin kein
experte in ethischen fragen i  Ich bin kein
Experte für die Ethik der KI
oder für Ethik im Bereich der
Robotik oder ähnliches, aber ich
denke, dies ist eine sehr faszinierende Art von
Ansatz, es ist eine App  Aber was kann
ich ähm das ist eine Diskussion wert und ich hoffe sehr, und ich bin
ziemlich optimistisch, dass wir heute
eine spannende und inspirierende Diskussion
darüber haben,
also übergebe ich
dir noch einmal
vielen Dank, Arno, für die Einführung,
wie schon gesagt  Ich möchte
die Schlüsselfragen für die Diskussion
dieses wirklich interessanten Textes vorstellen, also zuerst,
was die Autoren unter
sinnvoller menschlicher Kontrolle und Lenkung verstehen,
wichtige
Konzepte, dann die zweite Frage,
was die notwendigen Bedingungen sind,
die ein autonomes System erfüllen muss
unter sinnvoller menschlicher Kontrolle bleiben
und schließlich, wer für
autonome Systeme verantwortlich ist und
inwieweit autonome Systeme als autonom bezeichnet werden können.
Dies bezieht sich auf
den Begriff
einer Verantwortungslücke, die Sie
als Teil der Schlüsselwörter zu diesem
Artikel sehen könnten
in der diskussion stoppe ich jetzt
die aufzeichnung und dann fahren wir
mit den
diskussionsgruppen fort